hi these are going to be
bite-sized pieces of the 20 joe suburi
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
be
uh rather than
talk about too much detail in within the
suburbs you can
see films on youtube and you can find
lots of information on the
on ken and joe the juan macken and joe
i've done about others but what i want
to do is
explain over the years what i've felt
uh is the right thing or wrong thing to
do
with each joe spurrie so they're going
to be as the same bite-sized pieces so
that you can
go away and be able to build on them
and then the next segment of film
will show you a few at a time
the thing to do is to not
be in a rush and uh
and just look at each piece and if it
fits in your mind
then use it if it doesn't make sense to
you
then it's my opinion not another
teacher's opinion
and just just discard it
it's what i've thought about over the
many years following cytosensing my
master
okay so the things not to do
don't bring this shell once you stand in
here tell me
that means small posture your toes in
front of you
fingers closed not loose but not too
tight just just comfortable
the small finger and the next finger up
is the
two that is holding it the firmest
you don't want this shoulder to come
around here
and then when you lift the jaw up it
come back again
in my book i say don't go backwards to
go forwards
so this is what i mean you don't repeat
something that is unnecessary what if
you're standing here why would you go
from here
to here you're wasting time you're using
milliseconds
okay so you're standing in here on me
your body is aligned do not
bring it round here to get your jaw like
this
now i'm square so for chokazuki
so i'm here at first you'll find it
difficult to reach the joe
right if you bend the knees
the body goes down it still doesn't help
you reach the joe
so you have to go slightly down and
forward
the shoulder doesn't come round
down and forward
oh
if the hand stops here and doesn't pass
the body
then you've stopped too short
the wrist must be in line with the end
of the body
at the end of the ski
try and get all the squeezy the power
parallel
in a nice flat line or
aim for your own solar plexus height
and another incorrect thing not to do
or to avoid
is to turn the front hand over like this
it's now twisted itself making
this feeling even if you don't see it
sometimes you will see people leaning
they go
like this
but joe your hands should end with the v
in the jar so it's got a little
squeezing
but not a twist
so one is correct one is incorrect
please watch
incorrect on both hands
correct on both hands
it's not there
it's not there so
correct check it each time you do it
correct it correct it
check it incorrect
check both hands one hand may be okay
the other one may not
until you get them correct
until you get correct correct
correct incorrect correct
incorrect correct
correct incorrect
correct incorrect incorrect
another fault
hit this finger do not put the finger
on the joe like this
you'll see people often do this with
their finger
the same with the can do not do this
you get your finger broken if it gets
hit
keep it always closed
chokum
the feeling of going down towards
your joe when you collect it it's as if
you're going to go
past your job but the timing has to be
correct
so that you don't pass it and leave the
joe
so don't go this feeling
don't have this feeling
but this feeling
so you're going through and forward
give the body the body hammer punch to
the skin
okay so
work on those sometimes these things
take
years but work on those and
these videos some will be released on
youtube but mainly they're being made
from my patreon site
so if you wish to know more and each
one will be detailed with the
pros and cons and i hope that you
enjoy them but please subscribe to the
patreon
my patreon site where you can see these
videos
and they will all be in detail for you
the link is at the bottom of the page
the next segment will be
kaishizuki thank you